rhett and Link are here rhett and Link
have one of the they got one of the
biggest shows on YouTube for sure good
mythical morning I think they got like 5
billion views or something like that
something crazy they got like it's one
of the it's it's it's such a big show on
YouTube that there's I think how many
YouTube channels do you have George's
asking you shows how many shows do you
when you go how many channels do you
have and they go you're counting it
might be seven seven shows you have
hidden channels why do you need so do
you do seven channels because you're
like we've all this idea for content but
we want to keep everything branded in a
certain way so let's separate everything
by channels is that the idea yeah I mean
well take good mythical morning as an
example right good mythical morning is
is on channel but it started out as a
channel called rhett and Link too
because it wasn't the main thing we were
doing I mean we were we were doing music
videos and sketches well and that was
the kind of making on - that was the
convention at the time so I think we
still have red link and then Rhett link
- Rhett link 3 written link 4 and
written link 5 but then they get
rebranded as we come up with ideas to
fill them I see so you start registering
how many red links do you have we may
have 7 I don't know I think there's I
think there's 7 and then you just figure
out how to fill in the brands as you go
right like we want to have 7 channels we
need to come up with seven ideas right
everyone likes rhett and Link 3 is now
so there's good mythical morning but
then when we started like the second or
third season we started doing a thing
where it's like hey let's just keep the
camera rolling and let's have a show
after the show which is more relaxed and
let's call that good mythical more and
then people are like yeah we're really
into that and we were originally putting
on our website back when we thought that
was a good idea and then we were like
let's just put this on YouTube so people
would actually watch it and we put that
on rhett and Link 3 so now rhettandlink
3 is good mythical more which has its
own following I see are there people who
watch mythical more but not mythical
morning I keep hearing about this
it's so relaxed I don't understand and
we just you know you just try things
yeah when you're putting out a video or
multiple videos every day on the
Internet and we've done over 1600
episodes a good mythical morning I mean
yeah I'm grateful that a lot of people
are watching but at the same time we can
still try things and if something
doesn't work we can just kind of forget
we ever tried throwing on the seventh
Channel yeah with another video how many
people do you have working for you or
how many people does the the
rhettandlink company encompass so we
have about almost 50 on the the mythical
side for us and then we also Smosh is is
under the mythical banner now - Wow
so they've got about 40 or so yeah
there's always a hundred people crazy it
really is I mean we started off just the
two of us in retz
garage with a card table like Wozniak
and jobs do you feel like one of you is
the woz and what is the jobs one the
conductor and one that actually no I'm
the one doing everything which one
allows me to take more credit that's how
I'm processing this yeah but so you guys
grew up together yeah your body's first
grade first grade have you gotten to a
point yet where you've gotten like okay
we need to take a real pause from this
whole thing a lot of people who came up
on YouTube and who find success there
they they talk about burning out and you
know because you put so much of yourself
in front of the camera I mean the more
you talk about everything that's going I
don't know you tell me how it is for you
I mean is that you find it so you talk
about yourself and if people just want
to get deeper yeah and it could drive
you crazy you are accountable for
everything that you say most people get
to just say [ __ ] yeah yeah but when
you're on YouTube and shultz you know
only when you're a comedian you're just
trying stuff on stage yeah or when
you're on YouTube because you do both
right like you know you're accountable
for everywhere I think that's what gets
to be the exhausting part is there's
immediate feedback
to everything that you say and you're
like I didn't I was just thinking it at
the time I don't even know what I was
saying I don't know what I was talking
about it in me think about it at least
we're not live I mean yeah it's not
right things can't be cut out cuz I have
a tendency to just kind of just let it
out and see what happens with it and
you're like that didn't work for me
let's and luckily on YouTube it's like
jump cuts are friendly so we actually we
actually don't do the jump cuts that was
something that like early on we were
like you know what if we're gonna start
our our version our talk show so when we
started good mythical morning we're like
no cuts we're just gonna do the videos
gonna be an unedited well and for a few
well minutes it was just that one camera
now we do have multiple cameras so I
would hope so if you got a hundred
people and one camera what are the
people doing because we were doing that
12 12 minutes where we didn't want to
edit it and it was conversational in the
first few years there was a lot of like
right when we would cut we would get a
fight right you talk about us like you
know working together for so long we had
like one one guy who we called him an
intern this is back in North Carolina
and we were starting this thing and we
would he would just be it was such a
small room he was you know you could
reach out and grab a shoulder at any
point when you were filming and this
dude Derek poor guy we would just roll
for 12 minutes and he was just supposed
to posted to YouTube he didn't know he
would have to endure sometimes like a
three-hour argument no in the three
hours that's not we were it wouldn't end
you know maybe not you would you would
never apologize and I would never give
up by the way you know there's a lot
shots
boiling under the surface when one guy
goes there's like a three-hour argument
no it was
I guess it's right there fighting about
after 12 minutes I don't know no I just
heard his feelings in some way yeah and
I didn't know that I did know like an
account feeling and you stomach that
during the 12 minutes cuz you're like I
just gotta make it there there's 12
minutes and then afterwards we but I bet
you could look in his eyes and see
exactly wanna watch this mythical more
[ __ ] oh yeah right
did you ever think about that like look
if we're gonna fight for three hours at
a time after we do ten minutes your
content leave the cameras on you right
and link eight rhettandlink could be
breaking up at anymore I would watch
every swing we've gotten we get those
comments we've gotten them since the
very beginning I mean we've been doing
so YouTube I guess for thirteen years
now and we constantly get comments oh
you guys this is about to end more than
ever this is going to be over at any
second but there's not really any threat
to that actually happen that's why we're
comfortable I mean if we seem like we're
at each other's throats occasionally
that's just honest I mean if we're we're
we're more like brothers really an old
marriage right and friends at this point
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]